hello everyone
welcome to today's session so we will be
starting here
in few more minutes
and we are also going to be streaming
this meeting live
so if anybody feels like you can also
watch this session
live on youtube right now and we are
going to be starting
at 6 30 p.m ist
so thank you all for joining today's
session
hello everyone so we are going to be
starting here in five more minutes
so if you have any questions uh while we
are doing the session please feel free
to post those questions
in the chat box we have team present
from each of the collaborative uh
partners who are doing
this data science and drug discovery
program together and i would be
introducing you to everybody very soon
so please feel free to post all of your
questions in the chat box and today our
mentors would be addressing those
questions
and our team will also be taking in
those questions so
thank you again for joining in today
wonderful
good evening everyone and welcome to
today's session
today we will speak about the upcoming
program
on data science and drug discovery
this program will introduce participants
to the application of data
science to important challenges in
clinical
and pharmaceutical applications using
practical examples that cover genomic
transcriptomic
and structural data this is a
collaborative program
and conduct and organized by
faba academy which is the federation of
asian biotech association
pharma toppers pine biotech usa
and pro-biotechnica research private
limited
let me now introduce you to the program
mentors
we have dr harpreet kaur who is a
certified omix logic trainer and expert
bioinformatician
she will guide the hands-on sessions and
assist participants with projects and
analysis
during the program her area of
specialization is in genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is the omics logic
project
mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis
he has a phd in computational biology
and over
10 years of experience working with
industry and academia
dr sujit thangar paliwar is the founder
of pharma toppers he has a phd in
machine learning chemo informatics
and natural language processing ilia
brodsky
is the co-founder and ceo of pine biotic
in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industry and academic partners who are
applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications ms nito singh
is the ceo and founder of pro
biotechnical research
private limited and specializes in life
science research and development
she's a gold medalist in mtech
biotechnology from
amity university my name
is beepsha biswas and i am the omixlogic
community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users who are part of our
bioinformatics community
managed by pine for those of you who are
joining us for the first time
i wanted to share about the omics logic
programs
that are a result of a close
collaboration between buying biotech
and innovative big data analytics
company
based in the us and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omics logic programs have
been
thoroughly tested around the world and
are known to lead to
excellent outcomes for students with
minimal bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research
omits logic is an international program
that is running in five
different regions with over 10 000 users
around the world
due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators who are helping refine the
local program
logistics and leveraging our online
training resources
adapting them to the needs of the
students and researchers around the
world
in this omics logic programs we combine
online sessions like we are doing today
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective
in the well-known and respected omics
logic programs
so what are the outcomes for a student
who attends one of these
omics logic programs these outcomes are
as follows
a student would learn to read and
understand bi-informatics literature
perform basic ngs data analysis
processing steps analyze data
and form hypothesis prepare data for
machine learning cross check
signals with the gene databases know
what type of data
is required to answer scientific
questions
create your own bioinformatics analysis
and present the results in an organized
way
all of these skills are essential in
bioinformatics
and can also be translated to other
fields
now i would like to invite elia brodsky
our ceo at buying biotech to talk more
about the upcoming program over to you
elia thank you
thank you beepster and good morning
everyone
so good morning my name is ilya brodsky
i'm the co-founder and
ceo of pine biotech our vision
is to enhance human health and
well-being by enabling biological
research and discovery with relevant
data solutions and
expert support and you can see a little
bit more about what we do at pine
biotech on our website
pine dash biotech.com our mission is
essentially to simplify
bioinformatics or data science and
advance research through our modular and
intuitive multi-omics analysis platform
that is powered by both human experience
and artificial intelligence
we offer training research support and
big data analytics tools
that are designed for research and
biomedical discovery
our mission is to support cutting edge
research
but also help many users solve big data
challenges by developing
innovative solutions in partners with
our partners
that are easy to use providing training
like this program that will enable users
to use
these tools effectively and to help
scientists
arrive at sound and reproducible results
based on data that they generate
so in my part of the webinar i will
share with you
a little bit of an industry perspective
on the growing demand for data
science skills and training in life
sciences
so i will briefly talk about my
perspective on how such skills can be
utilized in various projects that i have
been exposed to over the past few years
and provide a perspective on how this
program can help you
gain a an understanding about the
various domains within
bio and chemo informatics preparing you
for industry specific
or research-specific work and projects
in your future career
so let me start by talking a little bit
about why
omics and why genomic data has become so
central
in life sciences so after the discovery
of structure and function
of the dna molecule in the 1950s
that was about 70 years ago humans have
been on a tremendous
a worldwide effort to really discover
the meaning
and function of dna code and it took
almost 50 years from that time
to sequence the first human genome but
soon after that
the technology developed during that
time started evolving rapidly
so by 2015 the 1000 genome project
brought in a significant number of whole
genome sequences to the research
community
and in 2018 over 100 000 whole genomes
were already sequenced
today there is an ever increasing number
of genomic
transcriptomic proteomic and metagenomic
data sets that are available
to describe subcellular processes of
regulation
with highly detailed digital data
and so as a result we really live in an
era of omics data so this is data like
genomic where we talk about mutations
gene expression patterns and association
with clinical data
that can help identify molecular
biomarkers for diagnostics and therapy
selection
as well as an abundance of data that
allows for novel discoveries
that provide us with a better
understanding of complex diseases
at the subcellular molecular level
and help us identify targets for novel
drug design
and drug repurposing and so what we see
is that there is a
critical need to train all
levels of life science research and
support
in dealing with this data and so because
at the center of data generation
data analysis and decision making stand
people
that need to understand the logic of
data analysis so they need to know
in what ways to improve data collection
and what kind of data is needed
to perform the analysis they need to
understand what methods are needed and
how
these various heterogeneous data sets
can be integrated
and how the analysis methods can be
useful
in actual decision making what can be
trusted
and where do we expect model overfitting
or lack of representation
so really the skills of data management
and analysis
are needed across this whole spectrum of
applications in life science
and industry and so that's why our
company has developed the onyx logic
program
which are designed to provide training
and bioinformatics
enabling independent research that is
guided by mentors who have such
experience
but also through peer example and so
what we
are seeking to design is more than just
a training program
it's it's a growing community that has
a shared passion for data-driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science
and our goal is to enable students
clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research
using latest technology in data science
and so we hope that this program will be
one of the examples where you will
gain a clear perspective on the
application of bioinformatics
machine learning in ai and research as
well as clinical
industry and pharmaceutical applications
so to do that we will provide you with
access to tools and enabling
infrastructure we will expose you to the
analysis logic for real data sets how
one in industry or research would apply
such understanding to a real data set
and
provide you some project examples where
you could practice and develop your own
skills
and so we've designed this methodology
that allows you to
understand the way projects are
conducted by experts
by giving you access to the same methods
and big data analysis tools
and also opening up the perspective on
how you can apply additional methods and
variations to the same pipelines
to a novel discovery
so this program is going to give you
several
key understandings about
data science in research and industry
first of all
it's going to allow you to understand
the details of molecular or biomedical
data
which includes omics data how this omics
data can
be understood in the context of what's
happening within
the cell tissue and the whole system
it will also provide you with an
understanding of how the different
interactions between the molecular
features
are significant for a phenotype which is
the collection of all
expressed proteins in a given cell
and so then we'll talk about the
specifics of next generation sequencing
which is one of the
important data sets that allows us to
study
a variety of different signals that are
at the subcellular level understanding
how to process analyze integrate
and interpret these molecular signals
we'll then turn to a section on data
science where we will introduce you to
scripting practices
in r in python for statistical
methods of analysis and machine learning
how can you
load a data set and prepared into an
object how do you actually
analyze data using a variety of packages
how can those data sets be visualized
and what are the specific practices that
you should follow to make your
project reproducible and then finally
we will introduce you to computational
biology where we will look at protein
protein interactions
ligand protein interactions and
qualitative analysis
of structure activity relationships so
we will look at how you can
apply the understanding of 3d structures
and genomic function
to understand drug repurposing and
novel discovery and so what this program
will provide you with
is a clear perspective on genomics in
research
the application of processing tools for
big data
where genomics epigenomics
transcriptomics and proteomics data
are regularly processed on large
server infrastructures and allow you to
extract meaningful signal and structure
data for downstream analysis
we'll also discuss different types of
methods of rna quantification
where we will look at microarray data
and next generation sequencing
and compare the different types of
signals that allow us to extract
meaningful and biologically
interpretable information
now to give you a little bit of a
perspective on where
the industry is in terms of utilizing
such data
i'd like to share just a few examples
from my own experience
where such data has been useful to
understand specific types of
applications and different types of
industry and academic projects so
one of the things about omix data is
that
today you need access to tools that
provide you with
ability to understand patient
information using animal models
and oftentimes cell and organoid and
tissue
that could be modeling what happens in
the real
world and so to do that you have to
understand how the different layer
layers of data could be integrated
annotated
and modeled so that you can understand
the real biology
that takes place in an individual and so
one of the things that we see today is
the need
for data integration where we can take
information
about the behavior or the activity of an
animal model
where we can understand the genomic
components as well as their structural
applications and integrate that into a
model that can describe a biological
process
a lot of times such data could be used
for
biomarker discovery where we would like
to understand how a specific treatment
is effective or ineffective for a group
of patients
so we can do patient stratification
effectiveness of treatment
and an understanding of molecular
drivers behind specific
types of drug interactions with a
pathology
we can also look at small molecule
screening where the understanding of the
big data
generated through high throughput
experiments
can help us select a specific focus
library of molecules
and apply downstream analysis such as
docking to understand what will be an
effective
way to interact the ligand with the
protein and test
it in real life and obviously today we
live
in a pandemic so what's important is
we will see how genomic data from such
pandemics
and different pathogen can help us
interpret the uh different types of
manifestations of this disease and try
to understand
how the genomic component drives the
specific
interaction between the pathogen and the
immune system
understanding how the interaction
happens
and translating our understanding to the
structural components that have been
characterized
and will be important to understand in
terms of their specific domains
and the interactions with the host we
will also
talk about some examples where you can
appreciate
the benefits of structure and functional
analysis and
annotation to understand how
this impacts drug design as well as
vaccine design
and so to facilitate this program our
team
has been working hard to prepare
training materials
data analysis tools curated project data
sets and interactive sessions that are
designed for this type of
project-based learning so if any of
these
project examples that i've described up
until now sound
interesting and something that you are
interested in pursuing in your own
research or career
i think that you would benefit from such
training
and a lot of times it can be
overwhelming how do i actually get
started because
many of these projects include thousands
of samples with
large data sets they include complex
analytical tools that need to be
combined together into complicated
pipelines
and you need to be literate in different
types of analysis
methods packages visualization methods
and ways to deal with specific types of
data
so i think that one of the benefits of
this program
is that even a novice who has limited
experience
in programming bioinformatics pipelines
or big data analysis tools
will be able to leverage these elements
of the training program that we've
designed
to quickly get up to speed and be able
to conduct
independent research using some of these
tools and so how do these tools actually
work
well one example of such a tool is a
browser-based
coding environment where you can learn
coding in
r and python using specific
libraries that are commonly used for
data visualization
preparation and analysis where you will
learn
how to perform multivariate analysis of
onyx data
using clustering and dimensionality
reduction techniques
as well as looking at a variety of data
mining and classification methods
where you can train machine learning
models
to predict specific outcomes and
identify
relationships between significant
features that you
are informed about in your data now
these tutorials provide
a very clear code breakdown that code
breakdown could
actually be run inside the browser to
produce the results
and change those based on the input data
sets and so we've prepared a number of
project examples that range from basic
visualization
to advanced analysis of metagenomic
and transcriptomic and genomic data
including
examples that really illustrate how this
is applied in the world of
pharmacogenomics
research and applications to a variety
of clinical
and industry problems so i'm excited
to welcome you all to join this program
on the data science and drug discovery
where training is going to be provided
by real
experts in the field and you will gain
support
for a project or a specific type of a
research question
that you might want to ask in the
content in the context
of clinical and industry applications
so i would now like to pass it on to
dr mohit mizunder to speak about the
specifics
of the program schedule
okay
hello everyone am i audible now
yes yes
sorry about the interruption actually uh
the system i was using is not uh zoom
interrupted
so be sure can you share my slide dick
please
give me a moment uh doctor i'll share
your slightly
sure thank you and hello everyone uh
welcome to this webinar
and we'll be i'll be talking in just a
minute and
we'll be sharing my slides sorry for the
interruption
dr mason that you can continue while i
start uh go ahead and share your stream
yeah okay thank you and i would like to
thank you thanks india first for this
detailed overview about the
application of data science and its role
in drug discovery
so this research based training program
is basically designed to help young
researchers and students
to take advantage of the bioinformatics
resources
for analysis of complex high throughput
life science data
and also become versed in bioinformatics
so this program is designed basically
designed for everyone
without having uh prior knowledge of
bioinformatics
but to having a basic knowledge of
molecular biology
and the topics that we discussed uh so
far
so for everyone my name is
mohit mazumdar thank you peepsha my name
is mohit mazumdar and i'm one of the
global representatives of pine biotech
and my phd was focused on developing a
novel algorithm
method to identify and predict calcium
binding sites
and study its binding affinity towards
calcium so during that process i had to
master data mining skill sets and become
proficient at predictive
analysis as well in my current role i am
collaborating and working with academia
and industry
to provide support for bioinformatics
education and research
along with our hard working and
efficient team we have been able to work
with more than 30 universities for
research-based programs like this
and we've been able to help thousands of
students to develop
understanding of data-driven research in
life sciences
so today i wanted to guide you all
through this innovative research program
which is an
outcome of modern life science research
as you can see
so the application of machine learning
for drug discovery
and the application of genomics
microscopy
and quantum chemistry they have like
really created a
radical impact right and that holds the
potential
also to significantly accelerate the
process of this medic medical research
and vaccine development which is such a
necessary thing
uh like in this case that we are living
through this pandemic
uh uh like kovi 19. so
uh so before i talk more about the
details of
uh of these uh uh
about the details of the program uh
let's let's review this publication that
you can see on the screen
so this publication is a recent one
which could help us
understand the importance of developing
skill sets for the future and today's
modern
academic and industrial research so
why all of a sudden there has been an
increase in application of data science
and machine learning
so that's the question i'm asking so uh
also please feel free to write in the
chat if you have any questions if you
have any doubts about whatever we are
saying
and we can we will be able to address
those
so as i was telling you that why
so the reason is biomedical research is
increasingly becoming a high dimensional
science
so elia did talked about machine
learning and the dimensionality problem
and like how we are using multiple types
of data to
answer a research question so one of the
challenge
is the high dimensionality of this
data so especially in the pharmaceutical
industry now data is
getting generated like really at a
cheaper price
and because of that not only in pharma
but also in
academic setup and in a research lab so
because of that there is a problem
which is happening because of the
increase in complexity
and the diversity and the volume at
which this data is
growing so it's really at a fast pace so
this is a result
because of the development of these
noble technologies that came for
molecular profiling
imaging and other types of high
throughput readouts at an
unprecedented rate so how this is
influencing the
drug discovery pipeline and why
pharmaceutical and the industries
and the labs are adopting this and why
we should learn these
skill sets and you can see that that the
author here
describes how to incorporate successful
data science um to drug discovery
pipeline right
and that eventually cutting the cost uh
dramatically
and also reducing the time so this has
been implemented by most of the software
industry
most of the pharmaceutical industry and
also small biotechs
along with that the academic setup where
we are
going for phds when we are applying for
master projects or masters
or we are applying for postdoc research
so this sort of research
is being carried out now at an
unprecedented rate where people are
expecting
to gain uh insights from this big data
because
this is something that have not been
done before that we have been able to
generate at
this at time line data where we can see
the disease progression
where we are using machine learning so
i'll be talking about
all of that but before that let's look
at the
um maybe beeps we can go to the next
slide and
understand that how this course is
actually
meant to give you an overview of what is
going on in modern
setup and what is going on in the
industry so now let's look at the entire
course curriculum and the units
so this special omix logic research this
this research program
is like an it's a very unique
opportunity for students
and researchers to learn in depth and
get guidance and support
by academic and industry international
industry experts
so in this program the participants will
work on
example ngs and structural data sets
and they will be able to explore
publicly available databases
and resources to work on their
independent and group projects
so this entire course will have 33
scheduled
sessions where the sessions will be
divided by
either online like the online sessions
right like we are having right now
also there will be coding sessions and
uh then
going through the tutorials you will
have to be go through the tutorials that
we will be
sharing every week uh before and after
the session
as a part of the asynchronous learning
so this program um
will have a lot of components and
one of the major component is a strong
feedback process
so you can see in there the highlighted
parts and assessments so they are
feedback
uh pro that's the feedback process so
the feedback process
actually helps us um
and also helps the participants to make
the most out of the resources
so and that also helps the mentors of
the program
for to evaluate and grade the
participant progress so there will be
literature review um there will be uh
other resources that we'll be sharing
with you so in this program we will have
several case studies that elia just
talked about and
the case studies that we have prepared
by uh
by working on by working before the
program and setting up
and looking at the data sets uh to help
understand
how you access how you can access and
understand the publicly available data
sets like
uh like on ncbi or like on tcga
and other repositories so uh now uh
let's look at briefly uh about the
entire course structure
so let's go to the next slide deep chat
thank you so uh so after like uh
doing the registration once you are
registered for the program so the
after the uh so after that the first
week uh until the first week of the
program
when the program is going to start the
participants who register will have
orientation and introduction sessions
where we will be collaboratively working
with the
participants to set up their academic
profile
and set up their accounts on big data
analytical platform tbi info platform
so this week and the time before that we
will be learning about big data
and an application of bioinformatics so
getting prepared for the the first week
of the
program and the time before that once
you register
will be focused on getting you prepared
for the program
so we will be able to help you
understand what is big data and how
bioinformatics is applied through
applied to these different problems so
the phase one so once this introduction
is complete and orientation
is complete the phase one of the program
will be focused on the genomic data
analysis
for biomedical drug discovery
so uh here uh we will start with the
basics so
we will start from uh where we will
start from the basics of understanding
of dna sequencing
and using techniques such as uh sequence
alignment
and mapping the raw raw sequencing reads
to the genome so the first week will be
uh starting of the genomics program or
genomics phase will be about
understanding the basics and
understanding about the techniques that
are very much popular
so in the complete genomic
genomics phase uh for biomedical drug
discovery
we will learn about ngs genomics so
sanger
genomics exon
and we will look at the wgs and wes
and then we will also learn about the
basics of dna code
and how variations can be
learned like we will be learning about
the mutations we love learning about
substitutions
and that would be pro that would be also
you will be able to also learn about
those
by looking at and by doing the courses
that will be
shared with you so genomics one an
introduction to genomics and then
dna code and variation then sequence
alignment and analysis and analysis in
genomics too
and then looking at the geos and
sequence and structure and function
which will be you know covered in the
session
so in this genomic phase we will also be
working on
projects so after the genomic phase is
over
in the second phase of the program we
will learn about the
second data type which is to understand
the application of transcriptomics
data in biomedical research
so in the in this phase we will be
learning about rna sequencing we will be
learning about differential gene
expression
and machine learning so uh in
in this phase we will also be learning
about how gene expression data can be
utilized in several of these
applications
in several disease types so we will
start from
how do how you can process the data we
will learn about mapping
we will learn about quantification then
we will learn about uh
normalization then we will learn about
exploratory data analysis
and differential gene expression and
then we will
think uh then we will uh trans uh trans
then we'll move to
machine learning so how you can
interpret the big data that is the gene
expression data
using machine learning techniques so
along with this regular webinars like we
are having now
and the practical exercises that we that
i talked about and on
then we will be all you will also be
having access to the online courses
so these resources that are that you can
see on the screen
they are uh their tutorials uh with
uh with a complete curriculum so each of
these course
uh covers an important aspect of
transcriptomics data analysis so when
you go through these courses you get an
overview of processing you get an
overview of statistical analysis
you get an overview of machine learning
tools and you also get an overview of
single cell data
analysis techniques which is a part of
machine transcriptomics four
so from one to four you kind of uh move
from
um another one level to another so these
will be a part of the program
uh which will also have in practical
examples so here
as i just as we discussed as we were
discussing about the practical examples
of the projects
so we already have prepared a various
examples you can pick from
ranging from biomedical to agri
agricultural studies
so some of the projects have been
developed for this program that have
been
that have been earlier mentioned by elia
but also i would like to mention
some of the projects that we have
prepared includes
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer so that is one project
drug repurposing of a drug resistance um
in liver cancer so that is another
project third project that we have
prepared is drug discovery for
alzheimer's disease
and then we have a kovic 19 drug
repurposing project as well
so this will be about the second phase
which is the transcriptomics phase so
we have completed so for two phases
first phase we learned about the
genomics
second phase we learned about the
transcriptomics and the
and there will be a lot of sessions
between these uh
between these two two two phases then we
will move into the third phase
so this is a four month program and we
will have uh you will have a lot of time
to go through
what i am describing for each of these
sections and you will have a lot of time
to discuss with the mentor
and you know we'll be able to guide you
through that process
so the third phase is about data science
so once you learn about the technology
now you will be able to
you know analyze it further using
machine learning techniques
so data science as you know has a
potential to make an impact
in all operational pipelines whether it
is in pharma whether it is in business
so data science has a very critical role
and especially in pharma
interestingly data science has been
making a lot of
impact for example in optimizing
clinical trial pipelines
there there have been a lot of cost
control so the third phase of the
program we will learn about the machine
machine learning to interpret and
analyze biomedical data
and this will be this will be this will
include like practicing on the coding
platform like helia showed
and to learn how to perform clustering
and
data mining and predictive analysis
using uh several of the machine learning
algorithms that you
you can see on the screen so yeah
so we will be using the ones that have
been popularly
popularly popularly used by the
scientific community to answer and to
find patterns in biological data
so along with these machine learning
algorithms
if you can go to the next slide we will
also be utilizing the resources that
we have developed for machine learning
uh
and ai that utilizes r and python so you
will be learning about so these are the
resources that
have been developed by tower
bioinformatics research center and the
partners and collaborators of pine
biotech
so we will be able to learn about how to
load data and do visualization
we'll be working with sequences and we
will be doing a as i said exploratory
data analysis
so we'll be utilizing statistics and
machine learning
in this entire phase of the program
so this entire so this um entire
expertise that you have developed by
learning about the multi-omics data
analysis by putting that
information and then applying machine
learning this could actually
help us or this could actually lead to
new pathways you can find new pathways
new targets
that you can work upon for the next step
so
the way the program has been designed is
is just like the
pipeline that you show that that you saw
at the beginning which is typically
shown by a pharma industry that how a
drug
start a drug discovery process takes
time that is like
10 to 15 years so what we are trying to
do here is that
we are trying to trying to uh understand
couple of
uh ngs data types and then we are trying
to understand
the application of machine learning then
we are coming to uh
those identifying those genes important
proteins
by doing gene set pathway analysis or
pathway enrichment analysis which will
be a part of the biological
interpretation
so after this the we have the fourth
phase
the fourth phase uh is about uh finding
the target so after you have found the
target in the fourth
phase of the program we will learn and
explore 3d structures
or our target proteins or the chemical
entities of the structural molecules
so to talk more about kami informatics
i would like to invite our industry
expert here today
uh dr sujeeth so over to you dr sujeeth
to to help us to guide us through the
fourth phase and
your expertise thank you and please feel
free to
put it in the chat i'll look into the
chat and i'll
answer if you have any questions related
to the program and what we have covered
so far thank you thank you dr mohit i
would love i would like to thank
uh india as well and pepsia for this
wonderful webinar
in collaboration with former doctors uh
pine biotech dobber institute provide
ignite provide technical
let me share my screen
good evening all of you this is dr sujit
tangarpalivar i'm a founder of
pharmacopos
currently i'm working as a lead data
scientist at aerometrics which is a
subsidiary of sun pharmaceuticals india
i have completed my phd from knifer
national institute of pharmaceutical
education and research
i have over 10 years of experience
industrial and academic experience in
artificial intelligence
machine learning natural language
processing computer vision and team
informatics area
i have developed a several industrial
usable
softwares in the field of data science
and chemo informatics during my
experience
as a industry industrial early data
scientist and as an
during my academic experience i have
published more than
13 research papers in peer review
journals and conferences
so to introduce about our company pharma
toppers we have around 20 plus
experts in our team we have the managers
to animators who animate those videos
which are in youtube
we have 10 advices from abroad and many
more
team compressors many more than this and
we are also specialized in gpa knight
perks
such kind of training national level
training program or a national level
guide
guidance program for the students
especially specifically for the pharma
students
so along with the gpa sniper we we also
provide drug inspector bits pilani and
manipal
uh entrance examination coaching along
with that we have several
industry oriented and skill development
program like clinical research
management
regulatory affairs data science dry lab
hands-on tools
specific topics and many so on so
in this collaboration with the pine
bio-us
pharma toppers india pro biotechnica and
sabah
federation of asian biotech association
we have collaboratively launched
a biomedical data science and drug
discovery program
a four month international intensive
industry oriented
program to help pharma life science
engineering graduates tool
to be to get ready for industry uh once
you
once you pass off from college you you
have no idea where to go where to apply
what to apply
but this program will help you to to get
your job and will help you to
make more clear understanding about
transcriptomics genomics data science
stuff and
chemo informatics although this program
is for
four months uh wherein a program is
divided into four different parts
but yes one can join only for a data
science
one can join only for a genomics one can
join only for a transcriptomizer or one
can join only for a team information and
yes
if you are interested in uh pursuing
your project finally a project with
us you are always always welcome to join
entire four months program
uh so that you know we will help you to
uh to
make a structure of your project final
year project or your
or we can we can have a publication out
of that out of
out of this entire exercise so we we
usually provide online guidance and
offline guidance as well till now we
have served more than 3 000 students we
we had five more than five
collaborations we sponsored several
seminar conferences and we have two
coaching centers in india
one is in chandigarh one is in hyderabad
so we have collaborated and acquisitions
with
several institutions in india like
provide technical hyderabad academy
neogenesis
and also we we we are uh
we are helping several uh entrepreneurs
to to
to grown up in the entrepreneurship
journey and there is a channel called
bows ahead in the fa
in the pharma topaz youtube channel as a
segment wherein we usually
uh give take a interview for all
interpret or successful entrepreneurs
or budding entrepreneurs from the any
any industry
so as dr mohit said you will be going
through genomics transcriptomics data
science along with the chemo informatics
so if i have to describe about chemo
informatics it is a field of information
technology that uses
computer and computer programs to
facilitate the collection storage
analysis and manipulation of large
computer
chemical data so chemical data here it
is in sense a drug molecule or a protein
molecule
so uh as most of you might be knowing or
might not be like chemo informative is a
mixture of many scientific areas like
informatics library science drug
discovery biology
toxicology text mining medicine
chemistry computer science etc etc
so yeah yeah in the entire post duration
you mostly learn about the data science
bioinformatics those are the
common keywords in the industry like
data science bioinformatics fema
informatics
and
drug discovery so what makes chemo
informatics different from the
bioinformatics
so in bioinformatics you usually learn
about biopolymer sequence of repeating
units
but in a theme informatics you usually
learn or mostly you learn about
technicals
and there is no sequence data and no
repeating units
so there is also a different molecular
descriptors and comparison methods in
between bioinformatics and human
informatics
so in the current industry people are
using uh
intensely they are using data science
technique like machine learning
artificial intelligence
natural language processing computer
vision technology in the chemical and
biological spaces
so there are multiple several companies
in india as well in
abroad out of india though and i i think
there are more than
250 startup startup companies who are
hiring only bioinformaticians and
teaming for information
those who know knowledge of a chemistry
or a biology or a life cycle of pharma
along with their data science skills so
now it is a must
for everyone to have data science skills
along with your domain knowledge called
uh for life science pharma chemo
informatics or bioinformatics
so what computer aided drug design you
might have heard the terminology called
cad
cad defines computer aided drug design
actually that
divides into two parts structure based
on degenerate drug design
in structure-based drug design usually
we we go ahead with a molecular talking
definitely will
in the entire session will have several
hands-on training with the molecular
docking
in our four months training course and
in the ligand-based
uh computer cad you will have mostly
molecular similarity method which is
usually used for the virtual training
approach
so in the session we'll have a hands-on
session on the virtual screening and
how we can convert how to identify heat
heat
how heat converts into a lead and lead
into a drug molecule
so there are some chemical notations
like dna rna we usually
do with cg and all these kind of
notations with the protein like with an
amino acid but for chemicals
we don't have any notations or know any
sequences so with the chemicals
we usually represent chemicals with a
smile structure
so these are the some computer readable
formats of a drug
called smiles or smarts or a smart
pattern and also some engine
rng formats for the drug so definitely
throughout this course you will come to
know you will learn about what are the
computer readable formats for those
drugs
how drug is getting buy into the protein
how protein is reacting in the body
to to cause any particular side effect
or to solve
any particular disease condition
and where will bioinformatics and chemo
informatics meet is like uh
epigenomic modification and dealing with
the data of chemically modified
biopolymers as
as we discussed bioinformatics deals
with the biopolymers and
chemical information scales with the
chemistry chemical data so
we can have a several sessions on a
chemically modified biopolymers which
which combines bioinformatics and team
information so that we will have
broader idea about bioinformatics and
team informatics
so i would like to now i would like to
pass on to
uh miss nathu singh for further
discussion on the
uh bioinformatics part and about her
company called by probiotic nika
nitu over to you
um hello uh dr sujit thank you so much
handing it over to me um very good
evening to everyone uh you guys are
learning
a lot about bioinformatics chemo
informatics and a lot more
uh so much of so much is heard and uh
you know um
delivered to you so um can you please
share my uh slides um i actually want to
thank ilya and mohit to you know uh take
me on board in such short notes
and um um i will look forward to how
um okay so i will take some time for you
to
share this okay uh so
we already have talked about so much
about bioinformatics and all that
and when i go to the ground level um in
the college
and when you talk to the student there
are still they have this dilemma that
so there are so many dilemmas still
going on
on the ground right so i just want to
deal with this very small thing and
everyone already have
explained very beautifully and very
elaborately
so i just want to i just want to you
know summarize all the data
and everything whatever we have
discussed in this webinar
so um so jet can you please share it
if you are like hearing me uh i think
i'm sharing my screen
yeah but actually i'm not able to see my
site
you can dr sujit we see your slides
actually
yeah you're sharing
if you want me uh me to share then i can
go ahead and also
oh yeah sure okay you have to go to the
pride slide
suji yeah yes okay so um
yes uh so uh my name is meetu i have
uh founded and i am the ceo of probiotic
and this idea actually came into my mind
only and only because
i had seen this personally that when we
were student we were
facing this problem that where to go for
the training where
the authentic training centers available
in the market
who are actually you know ready to
help us to enter our future properly
so um then i get this idea that okay
fine i have to find out something where
student and faculty that any ph
researcher can blindly you know just
trust us
first by our work only um so that is how
i just coined this thing we are just new
to the market we are the three four year
old but still we have collaboration with
cypress colleges
we have taken 30 plus uh training uh
batches uh
so yeah like we're doing quite well uh
physique can we can i see the next time
please
so um i'll give you a very uh brief
introduction of mine i have done my uh
kindred technology and gold medalists in
that uh from american
institute of biotechnology noida uh
campus
um the value which we want to actually
add to our services
is uh we don't want to you know only uh
take care of the student or the
faculties or
you know any individual uh or a group as
such but we actually want to add the
value to the
institutions to the faculties to the
industry as well
right so uh it's not that just uh a
student
is just a single student is like um uh
is is very good in one bioinformatics
training program
so um we are just you know uh done
with that we actually want the
institutions also to come up
and you know um seek for such type of
collaboration so that
they can because you know if you see the
market uh the students actually
believe their faculties so if their
faculty
are actually uh you know telling them
that okay fine this is something you can
if they pitch them definitely they uh
you know trust
somebody who are very new to the um you
know field
so we actually want to institutions to
come up and to you know go for such type
of collaboration
so just can you please uh change the
slide
you can hear me
yeah next one these are some of our
training and works and workshop which we
have
done this is what i was talking about we
not only
you know work for the students we
actually want to uh work with
institutions to the faculties also
in the industry so that we can actually
bridge the gap
what the students are studying in the
college and what actually the industry
is requiring um so did can you go for
the next slide
so uh the question arises uh
what is difference in bioinformatics in
21st century already
uh dr mojit already has emphasis
on this topic um i'll just have a quick
uh you know uh
some some sum up of this thing
initially when we talked about
bioinformatics we used just
uh simply used to think about this is
the biology mathematics
and the knowledge and the complex data
and we have to deal with that
but now the bioinformatics has changed
its meaning completely
it's not only the uh you know the
amalgamation of few
uh uh domains but it is it is that
basically
uh analyzing the whole data which is
ultimately going to the betterment of
the human being and the coronal virus is
actually the
the outbreak and the you know the quick
remedy of this virus
getting the vaccine just within one year
it's a mild it is a milestone for every
life science person
and if you see the global bioinformatics
market the size of this
is expected to witness a height of 19.8
percent which is really high right
by the end of 20-23 so uh yes
uh as it is discussed earlier as well
that yes it is
booming now uh life sciences but it's
not only the life and
it is the blend of bankrupt
bioinformatics chemo informatics
and data analysis and lots more right
and
and everyone has seen this thing so
my um this is only uh what we actually
have
wanted to uh you know talk about now i
will hand over this
uh to bitsha to you know further um
proceed
to the webinar thank you so much
everyone
thank you so much uh miss nido for
sharing this with us
now let me share about the program
resources so what are we going to
utilize
in this program in this four months of
trading program and how it will go so
you already
are familiar with the four phases of the
training program now how do you get
started with the training
so i'm going to be introducing you to
some of the resources
and also answer
any question that you may have
so the first resource that we offer is a
platform called
learn dot omics logic so
learn.omicslogic is our platform for
learning
now i would like to paste the link to
the platform on the chat box it's a free
platform
there are both paid and free resources
but just to get started
you can create an account on
learn.comics logic i'll also be showing
you in a while how to do that
and there are quite a number of free
resources that anybody
can get started with and as
part of this training program we'll also
be using
slack so slack is an app which you can
use
in your browser or in your mobile and
what we will do is we will have a slack
group
for all of our participants spread
across
the different phases of the program and
you can utilize slack to directly post
any questions that you may have
so these are the first two resources
that we will use
and the learn platform is something that
i recommend any participant
any faculty any researcher who is just
coming
and learning for the first time or
joining us here for the first time to
get started with you would notice that
in the login section you have both
logging via your email id or any of
these social media links
so you can get started and you'll find a
number of resources
i will be sharing more about them very
very soon
so moving on as part of this training
and throughout this four month program
you will also be
guided on how to use the tbio info
platform so this is a t bio info
data analysis server platform this
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management
and cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
and different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections
of this multi-omics pipeline so we are
also going to see
what this pipeline is all about now
india has also demonstrated to you
regarding the coding platform so we have
a platform called codemix logic
to train our participants in using r and
python to solve
biological questions so this is a
platform which again
every participant will have access to as
part of this four month training
whichever phase you are participating in
so our objective with the rn coding our
on python platform
is not to just train you in either r or
python
but to help utilize them as tools for
biological data analysis
now i wanted to highlight before i go
ahead and show you some of these
platforms in action
the uh you know the outcomes that other
participants have received so these are
some of these
participants sharing about these
outcomes
from linkedin so some of these
participants have worked on a project
for example urja
she has worked on a project with us on
differential identification of
biomarkers
between normal neural stem cells and
glioblastoma stem cells using
rna-seq analysis which has been
published she is working towards
attending several different seminars and
presenting them
so what our objective is to help you get
started on a journey
and the project that you do it's not
going to only help you
uh say for example do your maybe the
final year
project but something that you can take
forward and do more with it like you
know even
deeper research into this so we will
want to help you get started with that
along with the support of a mentor team
and these are just some of these
few examples that i wanted to share with
you all
as we are getting started
so here are these examples so now let me
quickly take you through some of the
different resources right here so i'm
sure that most of you have already
registered on this portal this is very
necessary that you are registered here
so if you're registered here you will
receive all the details on how to attend
this program the cost what are the
different
breakdown of the costs across the
different four sessions
so you will come to know about these and
i have also posted the link to this
whatsapp group
so we have this whatsapp group for all
participants that you are welcome to
join in
and now let us look at the platforms
that i just described
so this is the first platform again
called learn.oxlogic
so let us just quickly log in and see so
i'm already
you know i already have an account here
so you can see that my account is here
uh i can just sign in so if you want to
go ahead and sign
in with me you can go ahead and do that
and then once you come into the platform
you will notice that there are several
different courses
so let us talk about a little bit about
genomics because we
have genomics as the first part of the
program
so you will notice that once you are
inside genomics you will come across
several different lessons which are
divided
here and you will be able to take each
of these lessons once you are registered
so any lesson that is marked with a star
is a premium lesson
that is only available to program
participants or if you have a special
license but otherwise
all participants are also welcome to
explore some of these free lessons like
i would recommend you if you are going
to get started introduction to genomics
is a great lesson to
get started with so similarly you will
notice that there are several different
courses on different topics as well as
projects that you can explore
now the other platform that i was
talking about is the server t by info
platform
now i am not going to be showing you a
demo of this platform just yet but just
work through the different uh
areas of analysis that you see on the
platform so you see there is an
area for transcriptomics genomics dna
rna
which also has metagenomics included in
it
and each time you use this platform
you can highlight on each section of
this platform to understand what
is it that you are doing so we will be
guiding
all participants on using this platform
and the benefit is that
you can actually analyze a large data
set
using this platform and every
participant will have
five terabytes of space in the cloud to
run the different pipelines
so we will be talking more about the
platform in our upcoming webinars and
sessions and probably have a demo so i
don't want to spend more time here
the third platform is going to be code
or mx logic
so as you see on the codomex logic
platform we have
lessons like how to get started with
data science using python how to get
started with buying for matrix using
python similarly
how to get started with bioinformatics
using r
and the best part is that any
participant does not necessarily need to
install
r or python on their computer
they can just get started by using the
code blocks which would be provided
in the courses right here so these are
the three platforms that
we will be talking about and utilizing
as part
of this four month training and these
would be
supplementary to the online sessions
that we will be having
so the online sessions would be over
zoom like we are having today
and we will be doing that so i also
wanted to invite you all to go ahead and
join
our linkedin and facebook group so these
are just some of the groups
that we have on our uh bioinformatics
research community that you can join and
you will be able to see that
these groups do not only have students
like you but also has
researchers faculty administrators
who are all working and even industry
specialists who work
in this domain and they will be sharing
updates in this group you will be
learning more about job opportunities
as well when you're part of either of
this group and we also share
all of our videos like for example this
video is currently live
on our youtube channel so you can also
go ahead and follow us on youtube as
well now let me quickly get back
to the presentation because i want to
open this session for any questions that
you may have
and also ask you all to take part in a
poll
so i'm launching a poll on the screen
now this poll will help us determine
what is the right time
to have the maximum number of you be
part of a program like this because we
understand a lot of you are having
exams so please participate in the poll
so we have asked you the first question
which is what are the best
months for you to be able to attend this
training
is it from march to june from april to
july from may to august or
others if you select others please put
that others down in the
chat right now okay herman thank you so
much for letting us know
so you can choose a first option right
then what time of the day would you
prefer to attend this training scheduled
so all of these sessions that dr mohit
showed the 33 sessions
are going to be at around
one hour session so we usually have one
hour sessions like this
it can go to one hour 30 minutes
sometimes the topic is
more in depth but nothing beyond two
hours so
uh please let us know the maximum number
of votes will decide you know what is
the time they should fix
for having a training like this so i see
that
a lot of you are going for 6 p.m to 7
p.m isd
so let us and also would you want to
attend this full training program now as
we mentioned that uh we also have the
training available for you to take in
part that you can either choose genomics
you can either choose transcriptomics
or chemo informatics that is completely
up to you
and what are your research interests so
we also understand that
we do have research interests from
various people who may be interested
maybe drug discovery may be in
infectious diseases or anything else
so please feel free to post it and if
you are writing others please you can
post that
in the chat box and how familiar are you
with buying for matrix
so if you are a beginner and you do not
have an idea
of what bioinformatics is it is
all right we have a lot of these
participants for example urja who you
saw
doing that project she came in with not
much
idea of what bioinformatics is and was
able to do a project in a period of
three months
so it is not impossible at all these
resources
as well as the mentors would be helping
you
to achieve that goal that you have of
learning bioinformatics
and also understanding how to apply it
so we'll teach you the
logic and then you apply the logic to
your own research projects
so i'll keep this poll on for a
few more minutes and then i'll be
closing down the poll
i do hope that we can get a majority
vote on this so that you're able to
decide on the date and the time which we
will be emailing everyone by next week
so uh herman you can reach out to us so
my email id would be marketing at
pine.bio
i will put it down in the chat box in
case
someone needs to reach out to us
regarding this program
so please email me regarding any of
these questions that you may have
and if you all have any other questions
please ask us
right now so we will be closing this
session soon so
please let us know
okay so i would be ending the poll right
now i see a lot
more of you are voting for the poll
so maybe i'll keep it open and
okay okay so let me keep it open for
another minute
yeah and any questions again if you have
regarding any of the
uh courses that we share today like any
of the
sessions that we are going to be doing
please ask us
and please let us run you can save my
email id marketing at find.bio if you
have already registered for the program
and you've filled out that form you will
receive an email from me and you will
receive
quite a number of emails from me so
please make sure that
you are saving the email id now i'm
ending the poll
and thank you all again for sharing
about
the intended time and how you would be
able to attend these sessions thank you
all again
so i'll also share the results right now
on the screen
so that everybody can take a look at
this
you are welcome nashi
great to see that many of you are
beginners and would love to
learn more a lot of you are also
uh interested in drug discovery then i
see infectious diseases if you want to
attend the full training i understand a
lot of you are interested a lot of you
are not that is great
so i see 6 p.m to 7 p.m ist is a good
time for
the majority of the people here while
may to occur seems like
you know the majority for everyone so
thank you all for sharing this this is
really helpful for
us and again
go ahead and follow us on our social
media channels and now i would like to
invite dr sujit to share a few words
before we end today's session dr sujit
over to you
uh thank you biph uh hey guys
very very very thank you to all of you
that you have attended today's
webinar and uh this is a free webinar
which we have conducted along with this
we will be conducting one more webinar
probably in the next next week uh we
will keep you posted about the dates of
the next webinar
and uh as as we have mentioned we have
we have another collaborator called faba
federation of asian biotech association
and uh the next webinar we will have
some
uh some great personality from the fab
of in the next webinar as well
and along with as i could see there are
several phd students
faculty members masters and rap
undergrad students
so i would i would encourage all of you
to join this course
either for any of the course or for the
entire course
and also if you are if you are
you know ready to uh go ahead with your
project finally a project
proposal with us along with the paper
publication we will be happy to
happy to serve you for for project
designing defining and
doing all the all such projects in the
data science and biology or chemistry
domain
so thank you all of you for your
participation
and
thank you so much dr sujit and i want to
thank everybody
for joining us today so we'll again send
you the update for the upcoming webinar
and please feel free to join our groups
to reach out to us on whatsapp we
welcome you to ask any questions that
you may have
and have a lovely evening everyone thank
you all
and we'll see you all soon thank you